let's say that we're interested in
approximating what the square root of
four point three six
is equal to so we want to figure a pro
we want to figure out an approximation
of this and we don't have a calculator
at hand
well one way to think about is we know
what we know what the square root of
four is we know that this is positive
two the principal root of four is
positive two so you see okay this is
going to be a little bit more than two
but let's say that we wanna get a little
bit more accurate and so i want to show
you in this video is a method for doing
that for approximating the value of a
function near near a value where we
already know the value so what am i
talking about so let's just imagine that
we had the function we have the function
f of x
is equal to the square root of x which
is of course the same thing as x
to the one-half power
so we know what f of 2 is we know
we know that f of 2 oh sorry we know
that f of 4 is
we know that f of 4 is the square root
of 4 which is going to be equal to 2 or
the principal root of 4 which is equal
to positive 2. and what we want to
approximate we want to figure out what f
of
we want to figure out what f of 4.36
is equal to
this is just another way of framing the
exact same question that we started off
this video
so let's just imagine our function
let's just imagine it for a second
so
let me draw some axes
this is my y-axis
this is my
this is my x-axis
and let's graph y is equal to f of x
so let's say it looks something like
this
y equals f of x looks something like
that
so that's pretty decent
all right so that's
that right there is y is equal to f of x
and we know f of four is equal to two
f of four is equal to two so this is
when x is equal to four
i haven't drawn it really to scale but
hopefully this is clear enough so that
right over here is going to be 2 that's
f 4. and what we want to approximate is
f of 4.36
so 4.36 might be right around
right around there
and so we want to approximate we want to
approximate this
y value right over here we want to
approximate
that right over here is f of
4.36 and once again we're assuming we
don't have a calculator at hand
so how can we do that using what we know
about derivatives
well what if we were to figure out an
equation
for the line that is tangent to the
point
to tangent to this point right over here
so the equation of the tangent line at x
is equal to four and then we use that
linearization that linearization to find
to approximate values local to it and
this technique is called local
linearization so what i'm saying is
let's figure out what this equation of
this line is let's call that
l of x and then we can use that to apply
then we can evaluate that at 4.36
and hopefully that'll be a little bit
easier to do than to try to figure out
this right over here so how would we do
that
well one way to think about it obviously
there's many ways to express a line but
one way to think about it is okay it's
going to l of x
is going to be
let's it's going to be
it's going to be f of 4
it's going to be f 4 which is 2
it's going to be f 4
plus
the slope
the slope at at x equals 4 which is of
course the derivative f prime of 4 so
that's going to be the slope of this
line of l of x is f prime of 4.
let me make that clear so this right
over here is the slope
the slope when x is at at x equals 4 so
it's the slope of this entire line and
so any other point on this is going to
be f of 4 plus the slope times how far
you are away from x equals 4. so it's
going to be times
x
minus four let's just let's just
validate that this makes sense when we
put
4.36 here when we put 4.36 or actually
let me zoom in on this graph just to
make things a little bit clearer
so
if this is so i'm going to do a zoom in
i'm going to do a zoom in
i'm going to try to zoom in into
this region right over here
so
this is the point
this is the point four comma f of four
and we are going to graph l of x
so let me do that so this right over
here is
l of x
that's l of x and let's say this right
over here
this right over here is the point
4.36 comma f of
4.36 and the way we're going to
approximate this value is to figure out
what to figure out what this value is
right over here and what is this one
going to be this right over here is
going to be this is going to be
4.36 comma l of
4.36 this line evaluated when x is equal
to 4.36 and what is that going to be
what is that going to be equal to
well let's see let's just evaluate it l
of 4.36 is going to be f of 4 so it's
going to be 2
plus the derivative so the slope of this
line plus f prime
of 4
times x minus 4. so 4.36 minus 4 is
going to be times 0.36
and that makes sense you're starting at
2 and you're saying okay my change in x
my change in x is 4.36
so my change in y is going to be my
slope times that change in x to get me
that value to get you that value right
over there so let's figure out let's
figure out what this
let's figure out what this thing
what this thing
actually is
so to do that we need to figure out f
prime before so let's go back up here
i'll try to leave actually i'll leave
this little visualization here
so let's see f prime
f prime of x is going to be
one half x to the negative one half just
using the power rule over here so f
prime of four
f prime of four is equal to one half
times four to the negative one-half
which is of course equal to
one-half times
one-half four to the one-half would be
two four to the negative one-half is
going to be one-half so this is equal to
1 4.
so l of we deserve a little bit of a
drum roll now
l of
4.36
is equal to f of 4.
it's equal to f of 4 which is let me
just rewrite it it's f 4
plus f prime of 4
plus
g why am i switching to that color let
me do the yellow
plus
f prime of 4
times
times
times
4.36
4.36
let me make this actually a new color
just so we see it so four point three
six so times four point three six
minus four
minus four and actually let me make all
the four as one color too so you see
it's it's the same so
just like that so what is this going to
be
well this we already established is
positive 2.
this we already established let me do
this in the yellow color
this we already established is
one-fourth
and this part right over here is
0.36 so this is going to be equal to
2
plus 1 4 times 0.36 is 0.9 or 0.09
so this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to
2.09 so that is our approximation and it
should be at least waste on how i
graphed it a little bit higher than the
actual value of the square root of 4.36
but we could write that up here this is
going to be approximately let me just
write it this way
the square root i'll just write down
here so we could say the square root of
4.36 which is the same thing as f of
4.36
this is approximately equal to 2.09
now let's just say we happen to find a
calculator and just out of curiosity
let's see how good of an approximation
this actually is
let's get a calculator out and so we
want to do the square root of
4.36
and we get
2.08
so we actually if we round to the
nearest hundredths we got a pretty good
approximation and just like we saw in
this in this indicative graph right over
here it is our approximation was indeed
a little bit higher than the actual
value